after weeks of negotiations today we
have made a decisive breakthrough The
Windsor framework delivers free-flowing
trade within the whole United Kingdom it
protects Northern Ireland's place in our
Union and it safeguards sovereignty for
the people of Northern Ireland by
achieving all this it preserves the
delicate balance inherent in the Belfast
Good Friday agreement
and Mr Speaker
it does what many said could not be done
removing thousands of pages of EU laws
and making permanent legally binding
changes to the protocol treaty itself
that is the Breakthrough we have made
those are the changes we will deliver
and now is the time to move forward as
one United Kingdom
[Music]
[Applause]
Mr Speaker before I turn to the details
let us remind ourselves why this matters
it matters because at the heart of the
Belfast Good Friday agreement and the
reason it's endured for a quarter of a
century
it's equal respect for the aspirations
and identities of all communities and
all its three strands
but the Northern Ireland protocol has
undermined that balance how can we say
the protocol protects the Belfast Good
Friday agreement when it has caused the
institutions of that agreement to
collapse
so in line with our legal
responsibilities we are acting today to
preserve the balance of that agreement
and chart a new way forward for Northern
Ireland I pay tribute to our European
friends for recognizing the Need For
Change particularly president vondoline
my predecessors for laying the
groundwork for today's agreement and
oh yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
and my right honorable friends the
foreign and Northern Ireland secretaries
for their perseverance
[Applause]
finally persuading to the EU to do what
it spent years refusing to do to rewrite
the treaty and replace it with a radical
legally binding new framework
today's agreement has three equally
important objectives
first allowing trade to flow freely
within our UK internal Market second
protecting Northern Ireland's place in
our Union and third safeguarding
sovereignty and closing the Democratic
deficit let me take each in turn
Mr Speaker call to the problems with the
protocol was that it treated Goods
moving from Great Britain to Northern
Ireland as if they were crossing an
international Customs border this
created extra costs and paperwork for
businesses who had to fill out complex
Customs declarations a limited choice
for the people of Northern Ireland and
it undermined the UK internal Market
Market a matter of identity as well as
economics
today's agreement removes any sense of a
border in the IRSC and ensures the free
flow of trade within the UK
we have secured a key negotiating
objective the introduction of a new
Green Lane for goods destined for
Northern Ireland with a separate red
lane for those going to the EU within
the Green Lane burdensome Customs
bureaucracy will be scrapped and
replaced with data sharing of ordinary
existing commercial information
routing checks and tests will also be
scrapped the only checks will be those
required to stop Smugglers and criminals
and our new Green Lane will be open to a
broad comprehensive range of businesses
across the United Kingdom I'm pleased to
say we have also permanently protected
tariff free movement of all types of
Steel into Northern Ireland
it's going the other way from Northern
Ireland to Great Britain we have
scrapped export declarations delivering
finely completely unfettered trade and
Mr Speaker the commitment to establish
the Green Lane is achieved by a legally
binding Amendment to the text of the
treaty itself this is fundamental
far-reaching change and it permanently
removes the Border in the Irish sea
Mr Speaker perhaps the single most
important area of trade between Great
Britain and Northern Ireland is food
three-quarters of the food in Northern
Ireland Supermarket comes from the rest
of the UK
yet the protocol applied the same
burdens on shipments from Karen Ryan to
Lan as between hollyhead and Dublin if
it was implemented in full
we would see Supermarket lorries leading
hundreds of certificates for every
individual item
every single document checked so
Supermarket state
less choice so today's agreement fixes
all this with a new permanent legally
abiding approach to food we will expand
the Green Lane to food retailers and not
just supermarkets but wholesalers and
Hospitality too instead of hundreds of
certificates lorries will make one
simple digital declaration to confirm
that Goods will remain in Northern
Ireland visual inspections will be cut
from 100 now to just five percent
physical checks and tests will be
scrapped unless we suspect fraud
smuggling or disease and so there will
be no need for vets in warehouses
of course to deliver this we need to
reassure the EU that food imports won't
be taken into Ireland so we will ask
retailers to Mark a small number of
particularly high risk food products as
not for EU with a phase rollout of this
requirement to give them the time to
adjust
and more fundamentally we have delivered
a form of dual regulation for food the
single biggest sector by far for
East-West trade and one of the most
important in people's lives under the
protocol retail food products made to UK
standards could not be sold in Northern
Ireland
today's agreement completely changes
that this means the ban on British
products like sausages entering Northern
Ireland has now been scrapped
[Applause]
if it's available
if it's available on Supermarket shelves
in Great Britain
in Great Britain then it will be
available in Supermarket shelves in
Northern Ireland
we will still need to make sure that
Goods moved into Northern Ireland don't
risk bringing in animal and plant
diseases but that's clearly a common
sense measure never opposed by anyone to
prevent diseases circulating within the
long-standing single epidemiological
Zone on the island of Ireland and Mr
Speaker that brings me to the treatment
of parcels
if the protocol was fully implemented
every single parcel traveling between
Great Britain and Northern Ireland will
be subject to full International customs
you'd have needed a long complex form to
send every single parcel even a birthday
present for a niece or nephew and you
could have only stopped only shopped
online from retailers willing to deal
with all that bureaucracy
with some already pulling out of
Northern Ireland today's agreement fixes
all of this it achieves something we've
never achieved before removing
requirements of the EU Customs code for
people sending and receiving Parcels
families can rightly send packages to
each other without filling in forms
online retailers can serve customers in
Northern Ireland as they did before and
businesses can ship Parcels through the
Green Lane all underpinned by data
sharing by parcel operators where they
face rollout and time for them to adjust
so Mr Speaker no burdensome Customs
bureaucracy no routine checks bans on
food products scrapped steel tariff rate
quotas fixed tariff reimbursement scheme
approved vet inspections gone export
declarations gone Parcels paperwork gone
we have delivered what the people of
Northern Ireland asked for and the
command paper promise we have removed
the Border in the ira
[Applause]
but Mr Speaker but Mr Speaker
to preserve the balance
of the Belfast Good Friday agreement we
also need to protect Northern Ireland's
place in our Union The Windsor framework
is about making sure that Northern
Ireland gets the full benefit of being
part of the United Kingdom in every
respect under the protocol in too many
ways that simply wasn't the case
take tax when I was Chancellor it
frustrated me that when I cut VAT on
solar panels or beer Duty in pubs those
tax cuts didn't apply in Northern
Ireland
now we've amended the legal text of the
treaty so that critical vat and excise
changes will apply to the whole of the
United king
[Applause]
Dom there are rates of that on energy
saving materials will now apply in
Northern Ireland reforms to alcohol duty
to cut the cost of a pint in pubs will
now apply in Northern Ireland but
because we now have control over vat
policy we can make sure that the eu's
plan to reduce the vat threshold by ten
thousand pounds will not apply in
Northern Ireland and nor will the SME
that directive that would have brought
huge amounts of EU red tape for small
businesses we're also making subsidy
control Provisions work as intended
already just two percent of subsidy
measures in Northern Ireland fall within
the scope of the EU approvals under the
protocol nevertheless today's agreement
goes further addressing the so-called
reach back of EU state aid law it does
this by imposing stringent new tests for
the EU to argue we're in breach of their
rules they'd now have to demonstrate
that there is a real genuine and
material impact on Northern than
Ireland's trade with the EU that is a
much higher threshold than the protocol
limiting disputes to what the 2021
command paper called subsidies on a
significant scale relating directly to
Northern Ireland we've also protected
the special status of Agriculture and
fishery subsidies in Northern Ireland
which will be completely outside the
eu's common agricultural policy all of
which means the problem of reach back is
fixed as well as tax and spend the UK
government has a responsibility to
protect the supply of medicines to all
its citizens
our ability to do that
was constrained by the protocol
the biggest problem is that drugs
approved for use by the UK's medicines
regulator are not automatically
available in Northern Ireland imagine
someone suffering with cancer in Belfast
seeing a potentially life-changing new
drug available everywhere else in the UK
but unable to access it at home
and when the current grace period ends
in 2024 the situation will get worse
still expensive and burn some checks on
all medicines companies having to
manufacture drugs with two completely
different labels and Supply chains
pharmacies needing to check every
package with complex scanners and when
eighty percent of Northern Ireland's
medicines come from Great Britain those
frictions pose a serious risk to the
supply of medicines to the people of
Northern Ireland
to fix this today's agreement achieves
something unprecedented it provides dual
regulation for medicines the UK's
regulator will approve all drugs for the
whole UK Market including Northern
Ireland with no role for the European
medicines agency
this fully protects the supply of
medicines from Great Britain into
Northern Ireland and once again a
supremacy of UK regulation the same
medicines in the same packs with the
same labels will be available in every
Pharmacy and Hospital in the United
Kingdom and crucially dual regulation
means that Northern Ireland's
world-leading healthcare industry which
brings much needed jobs and investment
can still trade with both the EU and UK
markets this is a landmark deal for
patients in Northern Ireland it is a
permanent solution that brings peace of
mind
and Mr Speaker the protocol also banned
quintessentially British products going
to Northern Ireland when people wanted
to import oak trees to Mark her late
Majesty's Platinum Jubilee the protocol
stood in their way
it suspended the historic trade in seed
potatoes between Scotland and Northern
Ireland
and if implemented it would create
massive costs and bureaucracies for
people traveling around the UK with
their pets disrupting family life
and our family of Nations
that's why today's agreement will lift
the ban on shrubs plants and trees going
to Northern Ireland lift the ban on the
movement of seed potatoes particularly
important for Scottish businesses and we
will deliver this by expanding the
existing UK plant passport scheme and
when it comes to pets we have made sure
that people from Northern Ireland will
have completely free access to travel to
Great Britain and if you're a pet owner
traveling from Great Britain to Northern
Ireland just make sure your pet is
microchipped and then all you'll need to
do is simply tick a box when booking
your travel
so whether it's lower back rates lower
beer Duty Jubilee Oaks and garden
centers seamless travel with pets
seamless trade in seed potatoes or the
seamless supply of cutting-edge
medicines all of this now available for
everyone everywhere in the United
Kingdom
and Mr Speaker The Windsor framework
goes further still
safeguarding sovereignty for the people
of Northern Ireland and eliminating the
Democratic deficit
fundamentally the protocol meant the EU
could impose new laws on the people of
Northern Ireland without them having a
say
I know some members of this house whose
voices I deeply respect say that EU laws
should have no role whatsoever in
Northern Ireland I understand that view
I am sympathetic to it but for as long
as the people of Northern Ireland
continue to support their businesses
having privileged access to the EU
market and if we want to avoid a hard
border between Northern Ireland and
Ireland as we all do then there will be
some role for EU law so the question is
what is the absolute minimum amount
necessary to avoid a hard border
today's agreement scraps 1 700 pages of
EU law
amount of EU law that applies in
Northern Ireland is less than three
percent
and the people of Northern Ireland
retain the right to reject that three
percent through next year's consent vote
however that consent vote is about the
whole protocol so it cannot by its
nature provide oversight of individual
new laws and it does not address the
number one challenge to sovereignty made
by the protocol the ability of the EU to
impose new or amended Goods laws on
Northern Ireland without them having a
say
to address that today's agreement
introduces a new Stormont break the
storm won't break does more than just
give Northern Ireland a say over new EU
laws it means they can block them
how will this work the democratically
elected assembly can oppose new EU Goods
rules that would have significant and
lasting effects on their everyday lives
they will do so on the same basis as the
petition of concern mechanism in the
Good Friday agreement meaning the
support of 30 members from at least two
parties if that happens the UK
government will have a veto and we will
work with a Northern Ireland assembly
and all parties to codify how their UK
government will use that veto
and let me tell the House the full
significance of this breakthrough the
storm on break gives the institutions of
the Good Friday agreement a powerful new
Safeguard it means the United Kingdom
can veto new EU laws if they are not
supported by both communities in
Northern Ireland
and yes it is true that until now the EU
had refused to consider treaty change we
were told it was impossible the EU
negotiators would never consider it but
the storm on break has been introduced
by fundamentally rewriting the treaty
specifically the provisions relating to
Dynamic alignment that is a permanent
change it ends the automatic ratchet of
EU law and if the veto is used the
European courts can never overturn our
decision
and the EU have also explicitly accepted
an important principle in the political
declaration it is there in black and
white that the treaty is subject to the
Vienna convention
this means that unequivocally the legal
basis for the Windsor framework is in
international law I'd like to thank my
right honorable friend the member for
stone for his support in negotiating
this point and it puts beyond all doubt
that we have now taken back control
[Music]
Mr Speaker Mr
mid very start we have listened closely
and carefully to views on all sides of
this debate I'm grateful to many members
of this house the communities of
Northern Ireland and the voices of
business and Civil Society for putting
forward their suggestions I want to
particularly thank the Northern Ireland
business groups that I have spoken to
I hope in today's agreement they
recognize we have addressed their
concerns we are delivering stability
certainty Simplicity affordability and
clarity as well as strengthened
representation for the businesses of
Northern Ireland
I also want to speak directly to the
unionist community
I understand and have listened to your
frustrations and concerns and I would
not be standing here today if I did not
believe today's agreement marks a
turning point for the people of Northern
Ireland
it is clearly in the interests of the
people and those of us who are
passionate about the cause of unionism
for power sharing to return
of course parties will want to consider
the agreement in detail a process that
will need time and care
and there are of course many voices and
perspectives within Northern Ireland and
it is a job of government to respect
them all
but I have kept the concerns raised by
the elected representatives of unionism
at the Forefront of my mind because it
is their concerns with the protocol that
have been so pronounced and what I can
say is this our goal
has been to ensure the economic rights
of the people of Northern Ireland under
the act of Union and Belfast Good Friday
agreement placing them on an equal
footing with the rest of the UK with
respect to tax trade and the
availability of goods
and we have worked to end the prospect
of trade diversion removed any sense of
a border for UK internal trade removed
routine Customs or checks for goods
destined for Northern Ireland removed
thousands of pages of existing EU law
and introduced a UK veto on Dynamic
alignment through the Stormont break
we have created a form of dual
regulation where it works and it is
needed most in sectors like medicines
and food retail we have delivered
unfettered access to the whole UK market
for Northern Ireland's businesses and we
will take further steps to avoid
regulatory Divergence in future we've
secured a clear EU commitment and
process to manage future changes with a
special Goods body and all of this means
Northern Ireland's businesses have
continued access to the EU Market as
they requested
it means we have protected the letter
and the spirit of Northern Ireland's
constitutional guarantee in the Belfast
agreement with this storm on break
creating an effective cross-community
Safeguard there are Mr Speaker two
distinct economies on the island of
Ireland and that will remain the case
today's agreement puts beyond all doubt
that Northern Ireland's place in the
internal market and United Kingdom is
fully restored Mr Speaker I want to
conclude by directly addressing the
question of the Northern Ireland
protocol bill as I and my predecessors
always said
the bill was only ever meant to be a
last resort meant for a world where we
could not get negotiations going
said at the time of introduction
remains a negotiated solution
now that we've persuaded the EU to
fundamentally
Reba protocol we have
work delivers a decisively better
outcome than the bill achieving what
people said could not be done and what
the bill does not offer it permanently
removes any sense of a border in the
Irish sea it gives us control over
Dynamic alignment through the storm
won't break beyond what the bill
promised and the bill did not change a
thing in international law keeping the
jurisdiction of the ecj and leaving US
Open to months maybe years of
uncertainty disruption and legal
challenge today's agreement
makes binding legal changes to the
treaty itself and is explicitly based in
international law and unlike the bill it
is an agreement that provides certainty
stability and crucially can start
delivering benefits almost immediately
for the people and businesses of
Northern Ireland of course the house
would expect to be informed of the
government's updated legal position on
whether there is a lawful basis to
proceed with the bill so I'm publishing
it today it says that because we have
achieved a new negotiated agreement
which preserves the balance of the
Belfast Good Friday agreement the
original and sound justification legally
for the bill has now fallen away
in other words
neither do we need the bill and nor do
we have a credible basis to pursue it as
such we will no longer
and the European Union will no longer
proceed with their legal actions against
the UK
instead we will pursue the certainty of
a new way forward with the Windsor
framework and let me just remind The
House of the full breadth and
significance of what we have achieved
today we've achieved free-flowing trade
with a green Lane for goods nobody in
some customs bureaucracy no routine
checks on trade no paperwork whatsoever
for Northern Irish Goods moving into
Great Britain and no border in the Irish
sea we've protected Northern Ireland's
place in the union with state aid reach
back fixed the same tax rules applying
everywhere vet certificates for food
Laurie's gone the ban on British sausage
has gone past all paperwork gone pet
paperwork gone Gordon centers now
selling the same trees supermarkets
selling the same food and pharmacies
selling the same medicines and we've
safeguarded sovereignty for the people
of Northern Ireland with the Democratic
deficit closed the Vienna convention
confirmed thousands of pages of EU law
scrapped and with a storm on break we
have safeguarded democracy and
sovereignty for the people of Northern
Ireland so that is a choice before us Mr
Speaker let us seize the opportunity of
this moment the certainty of an
agreement that fixes the problems we
Face commands broad support and
consensus and offers us at last the
freedom to move forward together that is
what the people of Northern Ireland
deserve that is what the Windsor
framework delivers
as a conservative a brexiteer and a
unionist I believe passionately with my
head and my heart that this is the right
way forward right for Northern Ireland
right for our United Kingdom and I
commend it to this house